it's going to be kind of a bullpen day
because michael fuller is limited to
three innings in his start but what he
did his last time out
certainly can give this team a boost
today if he does it again now carlos
santana to the plate
so all lefties to face michael fulmer
out of the gate here's a line drive to
right field off the bat of santana right
to
harold castro whoa santana squared it up
adam pletko
in the rotation now nico goodrum leads
it off
line drive left center tough play
delinea shields with a great diving
catch
friend meow reyes the hottest indians
hitter will lead off the second inning
the pitch swung on line shot deep right
field this ball
gone from reyes went
upstairs and got a fastball and
tomahawked it into the seats in right
and he stays sizzling and the indians
have a one-nothing lead
on his fourth home run and cesar
hernandez swinging it left-handed will
step
in they're off with the pitch the 3-2
fastball got him off the plate inside
lindor
doubled down the right field line his
first time up
now the pitch lindor with a high drive
into deep right field
this ball gone and frankie lindor
coming out of it in a big way this
sunday afternoon
a double and now a towering two-run
blast to right
and the indians have a three-nothing
lead and lindor has his fourth home run
of the year
top of the order and nico goodram the
3-2 pitch
swinging a line drive base hitting the
left center field that's going to score
grayson grinder over the field
on a few skips as delino de shields he
gets the ball in quickly big turn and
hold for nico goodram line drive single
scores griner
tigers are on the board now trailing
three to one miguel cabrera the banner
and his team down two right back up the
middle
one run will score they're waving harold
castro home
cabrera comes through in the clutch to
tie it at three
here in the third two outs that brings
up jamer candelario
the 2-2 swinging the line drive down the
right field line it's a base hit into
the corner
cabrera around second heading to the
third jamer candelario heads to second
base you're gonna wave cabrera around
third base as the ball died in the right
field corner there will be no throw
how about that a triple for jamer
candelario the ball
died in the corner and by the time
naquin got to it ramon santiago brings
the big man home and the tigers take a
4-3 lead
the umps may have already said that
that's a ground rule double oh now he's
out
he just got tossed and the batter will
be
kristen stewart
in the air left field domingo santana
makes the catch
so one gun in the fifth and it'll bring
up jose ramirez
in the air to deep left field stewart's
gonna watch this one sail
way out of here jose ramirez with his
fifth home run of the year
that leads the club his team leading
17th run batted in
and the indians go up four to three
tyler naked win the batter the 1-0
swinging a ground ball to third base
harold castro in tight scoops it flips
over to candelario at first tyler
naikman bounces out
brings up miguel cabrera he's been
pretty aggressive in a lot of his at
bats
cabrera now shot to center that's going
to drop
harold castro's going to try and score
and he will
miguel cabrera delivered before he
delivers again
here in the fifth and we're tied up
again at four
as oliver perez comes on to face jamer
candelario with runners at first and
second
line drive base hit coming around third
are going to stop him and load the base
he ran through the stop sign
here's the throw to the plate and he got
him
and it is not kristen stewart cameron
mabin has come on to pinch it
here's the pitch from perez swung on
ground ball
up the middle hernandez to the back for
one over to first double play
second ejection of the day for detroit
it's cameron maben he was tossed by home
plate umpire dj rayburn
that'll bring up sandy leone to bat
left-handed
now the 1-0 a swing and a long drive by
sandy leonda deep right and gone
sandy leone has hit his
first home run as an indian
and the indians have gone deep four
times today
and now lead it by a score of
five to four and the indians
have runners at second and third with
one out
and suddenly a hot jose ramirez at the
plate
and that one is knocked down by the
second baseball but no play at home the
indians get another run
frankie lindor will bant right-handed
and the payoff pitch
and it's swung on and a line shot deep
left field down the line it goes
it'll one hop the wall extra bases for
lindor hernandez scores and frankie's in
with his third extra base hit of the day
a two out rbi double down the left field
line
carlos santana one for three with a
single he'll swing it right handed
seven four indians ground ball to third
charging scooping dowell lugo
even with a bag fires across the diamond
to candelario to get santana
reyes two for three an infield single
and uh solo homer to right
former is ready here it comes
and it's swung on blasted high and deep
to center
back goes jones looking up it is gone
again
my goodness and the indians with an
eight to four lead and
reyes with his second homer today third
in the series
and his fifth on the year second and
third for jamer candelario
single suddenly makes this a two-run
game now the one-two offering
another curve that's straight three wow
that leads it up to bradley zimmer who's
been a defensive replacement
all three games 3-2 fastball strike
three off the plate inside he got a
generous call yes he did
victor reyes at the plate swinging a
line drive base hit down the left field
line off the bat of reyes jacoby jones
around third and he will score
victor reyes will turn and hold double
single combination to start the ninth
inning
the potential tying run comes to the
plate here in the bottom of the ninth
inning
in the form of jonathan scope the one
strength delivery
and it's swung on bounce towards second
hernandez to second one
lindor's relay double play ball game